[Musique]
il y a quinze ans sur un quai de métro
d'un simple regard
un homme m'a sauvé la vie à cette époque
je suis un champ de ruines
je ne dors plus et tous les matins je
vomis du 100 ma tête en vrac je suis
hanté par des scènes de violence vécue
pour certaines en position de témoin et
pour d'autres en position de victime
mais trauma ce dont je me souviens et ce
dont je ne me souviens pas prennent
toute la place
à tel point que je n'ai qu'une seule
idée en tête que tout s'arrête
alors me voilà sur ce qu'est cette
histoire c'est mon histoire mais c'est
aussi la vôtre
nous sommes tous des traumatisés
qu est ce qu un trauma la médecine nous
dit que c'est une blessure due à un
impact la psychologie nous dit que c'est
un violent choc émotif qui perturbe la
personnalité d'un sujet et qui laissent
des traces durables
on peut souffrir d'un trauma à la suite
de violences comme ce fut mon cas on
peut aussi souffrir d'un trauma à la
suite d'un deuil d'un accident peut-être
que pour vous ce fut un abus un
licenciement
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est comment on
les regarde
- on les connaît et plus ils sont
radioactifs ils nous détournent de nos
trajectoires de vie peuvent nous faire
passer à côté d'une vraie histoire
d'amour du métier de nos rêves ou même
nous faire enchaîner les scénarios
catastrophe et nous conduire jusqu'à
l'exclusion
on sait par exemple que nombreux sdf
sont d'anciens enfants placés à
l'assistance publique des enfants
ballottés abandonnés et maltraités sur
ce quai de métro
c'est en ne regardant en m'empêchant de
sauter que l'homme que j'ai croisé
m'invita à regarder en face mais trauma
mais comment faire comment est-ce qu'on
guérit de ses traumas à ce moment là je
réalise que pour m'écrire un autre
présent il va me falloir de l'aide et me
faire accompagner je décide alors
d'entamer un chemin de développement
personnel en parallèle j'initie une
quête de vérité et j'embrasse on
carrière de journaliste ou je concentre
mon travail autour du syndrome post
traumatique chez les soldats de cette
double exploration intérieur et
extérieur je gagne et je garde un
enseignement la découverte de deux
espaces de deux chambres que nous avons
tous à l'intérieur
la première c'est la chambre des traumas
avec un grand t une sorte de zone de
turbulences
l'antre de nos chagrins de nos chaos
intérieur de nos fantômes familiaux et
justes a coûté la pièce de la créativité
celle de l'expression artistique de nos
talents de l'innovation des idées neuves
pendant longtemps je crois que ces deux
pièces sont étanches que ce sont comme
deux bunkers qui ne communique jamais et
contre toute attente je découvre que
métro mas et ma créativité sont en fait
qu aux locataires qu'ils sont
secrètement alliés et contre les deux
opère une sorte de vase communiquant que
plus je creuse plus je fais le vit plus
je trice moncao intérieure et plus alors
je laisse émerger profondément mes
potentiels
concrètement comment ça se passe
j'aimerais bien vous dire un mot de ce
procédé pour que voulez vous puissiez le
faire vôtre c'est très simple
dès que je fais la lumière
sur un souvenir enfoui dès que je creuse
et laisse remonter une émotion
bouleversante
dès que je déterre un chagrin venus
d'ailleurs
alors je gagne un mieux-être
alors ma santé s'améliore alors mes
projets professionnels deviennent
passionnant alors ma créativité se
déploie tant et si bien que dix ans
après ce fameux quai de métro
n'ayant jamais touché un seul pinceau de
ma vie je découvre que je peux peindre
chaque coup de pinceau est un obus que
je déterre de mon champ de bataille
intérieur
chaque trait est allé sur la toile au
couteau est une balafre que je comble
chaque toile est une mine anti
personnelle que je déterre et vous savez
quoi
quand un champ de bataille est
entièrement des mines et alors il peut
se transformer en terres fertiles
grâce à cette convalescence post
traumatique
je vais enfin pouvoir à ma hauteur
agir lors d'un grand moment de douleur
nationale novembre 2015
au lendemain des attentats je sens une
urgence à descendre dans la rue
place de la république à paris je fais
sans voler des milliers de confettis
dans le ciel des confettis en forme de
coeur qui génère de grandes bourrasques
d'amour
ce jour là le vent se fait mon complice
et des portes mais nu et jusque devant
le bataclan où le recueillement est à
son comble je commence seul et quelques
instants plus tard nous sommes une foule
dense et unis l'initiative individuelle
prend alors des allures de cérémonie
collective pendant deux 2 ans je vais
multiplier ses interventions poétiques
pour réenchanter le quotidien pour
susciter l'émerveillement et pour
inviter les parisiens à relever la tête
après les attaques au dessus de ces
gigantesques souffleuse naturels que
sont les bouches d'aération du métro je
distille mais confettis entièrement
biodégradable qui disparaîtront à la
première pluie je découvre que ce que je
dis en silence avec mes confettis est
largement perçue par d'autres qu'avec
mes semblables
nous nous rencontrons et que nous
tissons une oeuvre plus vaste plus
subtile aussi tous ensemble comme un
rituel universel de guérison c'est cette
expérience se fly in project qui
manqueront qui me conduit jusqu'à vous
ce soir pour plaider
oui plaidé pour que vous fassiez de
votre home à vos alliés
et si vous décidez d'emprunter cette
voie
alors je vous invite à faire trois choix
et je terminerai là dessus d'abord le
choix du courage d'avoir le courage de
zerg art d en face vos peurs vos ombre
d'aller regarder ce qui se cache
derrière d'oser poser des questions et
d'être prêt à accueillir leurs réponses
ensuite je vous invite à faire le choix
de la conscience
c'est en regardant en face sa propre
histoire que l'on peut aller plus loin
et ensuite en aider d'autres à déployer
leurs ailes
enfin et plus que tout je vous invite à
faire le choix de la responsabilité
nous ne sommes pas coupables des traumas
de nos ancêtres nous ne sommes pas
coupables de ce qui nous est arrivé dans
l'enfance ou dans la vie de manière
générale nous ne sommes pas coupables de
notre oumma visibles ou invisibles mais
nous avons la responsabilité de faire la
lumière sur ces blessures d'aller
soigner ses plaies pour ensuite
découvrir derrière les fabuleuses espace
de création qu'elle cachait ainsi de
cette manière nous avons la
responsabilité d'oeuvrer pour les
générations futures
on parle beaucoup d'écologie en ce
moment et c'est tant mieux
et bien moi ce soir je voudrais
insuffler avec vous ensemble un grand
mouvement d'écologie intérieur personnel
parce que c'est là que ça commence
un adulte qui travaillent sur lui c'est
un parent qui soulage ses enfants ses
petits enfants et tous ceux qui
viendront ensuite c'est un adulte
capable de montrer qu'il existe une voie
vers une vie harmonieuse épanouissante
et inspirante
ce soir je vous invite à soulever le
tapis pour y découvrir les blessures qui
dorment ici depuis si longtemps
je vous invite à tendre l'oreille pour
écouter les besoins de votre être
profond à mettre votre coeur blessé au
recyclage et enfin entendre cette petite
voix et toutes les merveilles qu'elle
vous souffle à l'oreille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]